[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
nuestro invitado de hoy es hacking al
kart wii consultor ensayista y
especialista sobre el islam en francia
buenas tardes es el clima el kart wii
hola recientemente usted escribió con
benjamín j y este libro editado por
fallar y es militantes de la exigencia
es un estudio exhaustivo sobre 1.460 y
garitas europeos de los cuales 700 son
franceses porque hablar de milán desde
la yihad y no de yihadistas
porque nos dimos cuenta de que los
yihadistas eran militantes en el sentido
de que adherían a una ideología la yihad
no es solamente una lectura de la
religión es una visión global del lugar
que ocupa la religión en la sociedad y
es una voluntad por transformar la
sociedad tampoco se trata de personas
que han caído en el sectarismo que son
víctimas de gurús que los controlan se
trata de militantes políticos así como
hay militantes de extrema izquierda y
militantes de extrema derecha eso es lo
que queremos mostrar como lo hicimos
analizamos el recorrido social
geográfico y biológico de 1400
yihadistas eso nunca se había hecho
hasta el momento y se utilizaban
muestras muy pequeñas aquí utilizamos un
método cuantitativo estadístico que da
una visión muy clara del fenómeno
y como distinguen exactamente entre sus
caritas militantes islamistas para
nosotros los yihadistas son todos
aquellos que se han unido a una
organización terrorista o que han
querido unirse a una organización
terrorista eso incluye a los terroristas
luego podemos hablar al respecto el
balah clan los hermanos koch y etcétera
pero también están todos los que se
fueron a siria y que fueron incriminados
hay una calificación penal de querer
unirse a una organización terrorista el
estado islámico era una organización
terrorista todas esas personas los que
cometieron atentados y los que se fueron
no cometieron atentados son considerados
yihadistas pero en qué momento se pasa
de la militancia al acto de violencia al
unirse a una organización terrorista y
al unirse a una organización terrorista
o bien se pasa a la acción poner bombas
matar personas o bien se participa en la
logística o como las mujeres hay un 20
por ciento de mujeres en nuestra muestra
que se unen al proyecto de sociedad
yihadista lo que se ve muy bien
de las mujeres es que el yihadismo no
solo se limita a la violencia el
yihadismo es una voluntad de hacer
sociedad con códigos con referencias con
una idea de cuál debe ser el lugar del
hombre en las mujeres encarnan esa parte
el yihadismo muy muy bien
en su conclusión usted es un poco
alarmista señora el cardinal decir que
francia podría ser el escenario de la
nueva generación de siga digas
porque francia teme que haya una
instrumentalización política del
fenómeno
es más que francia que es francia y
europa
hasta el momento el yihadismo se ha
desarrollado en escenarios de crisis
geopolítica en afganistán argelia y
bosnia irak de nuevo afganistán y luego
evidentemente en siria hoy en día lo que
vemos es que siria con el llamado que
creó el conflicto sirio multiplicó por
10 la cantidad de yihadistas potenciales
tan solo en francia y unos 10.000 hace
12 o 13 años se consideraba que habían
de michigan distas potenciales entonces
se multiplicó por 10 además ya no hay
escenarios de crisis en el exterior hay
una crisis en libia hay una crisis en
mali hay una crisis que está empezando
en níger pero no se cree que esos países
vayan a atraer yihadistas europeos al
contrario lo que vemos es que hay un
movimiento que se está desarrollando
cada vez más en francia y en europa
alrededor de la temática de la
islamofobia de estado que podría servir
como movilización como vector de
movilización para los yihadistas
así que lo que decimos es hay que tener
mucho cuidado el fenómeno no se ha
terminado y puede que no solo se haya
terminado sino que esté delante de
nosotros en europa cómo actuar hoy en
día existe insiste en la responsabilidad
de la sociedad civil musulmana en
francia que es la sociedad civil
musulmana en francia
son todos los musulmanes de la
cotidianidad que son primero franceses y
que son de confesión musulmana como
otros son de confesión católica vía
protestante lo que les decimos es y eso
fue lo que mostramos en la investigación
en la investigación el 90% de los
yihadistas tuvieron una ruptura
espiritual abandonaron la religión de
sus padres aunque fueran cristianos y
musulmanes de cierta manera los
musulmanes cambiaron de islam acogieron
lo que podemos llamar el sana yihadismo
y en la argumentación de la movilización
la interpretación religiosa es esencial
los argumentos religiosos son esenciales
y una manera de desvincularlos no digo
es radicalizar los digo desvincular a
los yihadistas es decirles sabes puedes
interpretar los libros sagrados las
escrituras los textos sagrados de una
manera distinta algunos dicen que hay
que escoger las armas que hay que
escoger la violencia que hay que cómo
decirlo distinguir a los que están en la
alianza de los que deben ser rechazados
pero hay otras lecturas del islam
con mucha frecuencia los yihadistas
rechazaron la religión de sus padres y
acogieron una visión ultra rigurosa
ultra conservadora y violenta de la
religión pero es posible hacerlos dudar
y es posible hacerlos dudar con
argumentos religiosos es ahí donde la
sociedad civil musulmana tiene un papel
mayor porque es ella quien tiene
legitimidad para difundir otra
interpretación del islam más abierta más
crítica y además también fundada en las
luces de la razón no solo en una forma
de oscurantismo de la pasión violenta
ese trabajo en francia sobre una lectura
crítica del islam
eso está relacionado con el tema de la
organización del islam en francia la
construcción del islam de francia son
dos cosas es un trabajo crítico
teológico sobre los textos y además es
un trabajo de organización en cuanto al
trabajo crítico teológico ahora hay
intelectuales franceses de origen
extranjero con frecuencia magrebí o no
esta tarde cubrí está mohamed mayara
fier hay religiosos pero también hay
historiadores que son musulmanes o que
no son musulmanes todos contribuyen a
hacer una lectura crítica de cómo se
hace una lectura crítica de la biblia es
decir una lectura que se salga del
literalismo y que permita devolver la
perspectiva conservando evidentemente
los fundamentos de la espiritualidad y
de la fe musulmanes pero saliendo de la
lectura sobre todo de los salafistas que
quieren imitar la vida del profeta en el
siglo séptimo algo que evidentemente no
tiene ningún sentido en la francia
contemporánea del siglo 21 esa lectura
se está difundiendo el problema es que
tiene enfrente un movimiento muy
de hecho proviene del mundo árabe y del
mundo musulmán que ha permitido imponer
una cierta lectura muy conservadora de
la religión y si la lectura es posible
liberarse de eso
es un gran combate es un gran combate
que no se limita a francia o europa es
un gran combate en el seno del mundo
musulmán lo que hay que saber es que
antes de las lecturas del islam político
o del islamismo había otras lecturas de
la religión como el islam político tenía
militantes logró hacer creer que su
lectura del islam era el islam el islam
por definición tiene múltiples lecturas
primero están las escuelas las escuelas
jurídicas hay ramas del islám que son
muy diferentes que están ligadas sobre
todo a eventos históricos y luego hay
interpretaciones que están más o menos
ancladas en la sociedad más o menos
ancladas en la moderna entonces eso
siempre ha existido y es absolutamente
necesario hacer que reviva esta
pluralidad es todavía más esencial en
francia que en el mundo musulmán porque
en el mundo musulmán hay una cultura
religiosa en la sociedad y en francia no
hay cultura religiosa en general y mucho
menos cultura musulmana en particular
pero hoy en día en francia de la nueva
generaciones
man es que usted quiere que sea visible
en su visible puede de cierta manera
concretar su voluntad de liberarse en
justamente de lo que se ha llamado en
milán - con su lado su venida de las
embajadas
así creo que está cada vez más alejada
de ese islam por una sencilla razón ese
islam era el islam de los padres es
decir de los inmigrantes de la primera
generación que se reunían por ejemplo
con imanes que venían de sus países de
origen los argelinos se alegraban de
escuchar el dialecto argentino y de oír
referencias religiosas muy conocidas en
argelia lo mismo para los marroquíes lo
mismo para los turcos con el rito hanafy
hoy en día los niños son cada vez más
franceses cada vez están menos
vinculados con los países de origen y
por ejemplo cuando se envía a un imán
proveniente del país de origen a
mezquitas en francia los niños los
jóvenes dicen pero quién es este imán
que no nos entiende que a veces no habla
francés y se habla francés lo habla con
un acento muy fuerte y sin conocer los
códigos culturales además finalmente
estos humanos extranjeros no conocen a
los jóvenes pero cuando te das un
llamado para que esa mayoría de
musulmanes él te más involucrada se sale
un poco de la visión de la religión como
una
privado no debería estar en el ámbito
privado sí porque sabe después de 250
muertos por actos de terrorismo
islamista y con todos los debates que
agitan a la sociedad francesa respecto
al islam es absolutamente necesario que
el conjunto de los franceses vea unos no
musulmanes integrados bien plantados
bien situados en su religión que sean
capaces de hablar al respecto y también
sean capaces de decir que el islam no es
la violencia no es el antisemitismo no
es el terrorismo es otra cosa
necesitamos su movilización simplemente
necesitamos verlos para tranquilizar al
resto de la población francesa y europea
muchas gracias al clima elkargi por
haber aceptado nuestra invitación
gracias a ustedes
y gracias a ustedes que ence france24 la
información continua
[Música]